so let's say there's a young person in
their car driving from Arizona to LA and
you have a quick phone call with them
what would be your tough-love
encouraging they're coming here to work
as a music producer music producer could
be anything within the industry but just
a general foundation it would be a
pretty long conversation but I would
start with saying like if you're gonna
come to LA be prepared for how
competitive is there's so many people
doing whatever it is you want to do
there's thousands of them already here
there's gonna be another thousand of
them coming tomorrow and they're all
probably gonna be better than you so
when you get here be prepared for that
and figure out what you're gonna do to
get better than them come here with the
mindset of I'm gonna have to really bust
my butt to make it because a lot of
people come here they think I'm so
talented my parents think I can sing one
of my teachers at my college said I'm
you know a great songwriter whatever
that's what everybody here is everybody
here is amazingly and amazingly talented
and beautiful and handsome and whatever
it is so that would be my first bit of
advice and then the other thing I would
say is be persistent
you can't quit you can't give up you
have to prepare for the long haul it's
not going to be quick you're not going
to come out here and land an audition
the first week you get here or produce a
song that goes on the radio you know for
years it could take you years be
prepared
you